[Music]
we had fantastic beasts and where to
find them then we had fantastic beasts
the crimes of Grindelwald but what is
the title of the third film as I
mentioned in my last video regarding
fantastic beasts we've learned that
release of the film was pushed back for
a number of reasons the first reason for
the push back was at the first two
installments of the five-part series
were not received very well by the
worldwide audience effectively prompting
a screenplay rewrite and an extension on
its release the second possible reason
is Kovac Kovac as a whole has had a
profound impact on the world and the
film industry is no exception
with many major films having to push
back their release dates the continual
extension of the film's release has left
fans extremely eager to know more what
is it about when is it coming out which
characters are going to be in it and
most of these questions have been left
unanswered the first film came out in
2016 the second in 2018 fantastic beasts
and where to find them and fantastic
beasts the crimes of Grindelwald
respectively but what's the name of the
third film going to be to begin to
speculate we need to take a look at what
we have and haven't yet seen in the
films we know that the crimes of
Grindelwald takes place in 1927 we know
that the last installment the fifth
takes place in 1945 or at least some of
it transpires in the year 1945 so in
order to determine what the third title
will be we need to take a look at what
happens in that 18 year gap or at least
look at what happens next I've got one
angle that I want to explore that I
think could relate heavily to the title
towards the end of the crimes of
Grindelwald a rather major plot point is
revealed to us credence peboan the
powerful obscure eel is Dumbledore's
long-lost brother Elias if this is true
and credence is in fact Dumbledore it is
huge news because it adds a major
character to Harry Potter canon in Rita
skeeters the life and lies of Albus
Dumbledore it's made very clear there's
a lot about the Dumbledore family the
public doesn't know so it's very
possible that they're related though
Grindelwald doesn't confirm who exactly
Elias his parents are since he refers to
Albus as the young man's brother we can
safely assume that he belongs to at
least one of Albus
Albus was the eldest son in the
Dumbledore family and his parents were
Percival and Kendra Dumbledore before
this point in time it was widely thought
that there were only three Dumbledore
children
Albus Aberforth and Arianna Arianna
actually has a lot of parallels to
credenzas character and though it's
unconfirmed that Ariana was an obscure
eole her history sort of suggested i
think this would only further support
the relationship between her and
credence who is also an obscure but if
Aurelius is a Dumbledore it's unlikely
he's the son of both Kendra and Percival
Percival was in Azkaban
from 1890 onward and there is no way
they could have conceived a child there
however there is always the possibility
that Kendra had a child with another man
while Percival was imprisoned this child
regardless of the father would be
Alice's half-brother if she gave birth
in 1898 a year before she died then
credence would be 27 or 28 and films
that we've seen so far
Kendra Shane might also explain why baby
Elias was on a ship bound for America so
barring all of that in mind my title
prediction is as follows fantastic
beasts The Lost Dumbledore I think that
the film is going to follow credence
quite closely and outline Alice's
discovery of his brother as well as
Grindelwald continual attempts to
manipulate him what do you guys think
what do you think the title of the third
fantastic beasts film is going to be let
us know down in the comments section
below
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]